Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Over Cursed.
Now this game was made in just two days
for the Asylum Game Jam.
The Asylum Game Jam is a horror-themed
game jam for making new and interesting fun games.
And I do appreciate the Stranger Things style intro-
even though I don't think this game has anything to do with that.
But it supposedly has stuff to do with the paranormal.
Overcursed Inc., what can I do for you?
Finally! What kept you?
There's some electromagnetic disturbance.
Probably an evil spirit, please do something!
Don't worry, I'll take care of it. I'm on the job!
Oh, hello! Awwww, hi Rocky!
I just stepped on you? Oh no, there you are.
Okay, do I need anything from my car maybe?
HELLOO?
Don't mind me, just gonna barge into the house where you called me from.
Okay.
Oh, this was made in two days? This is actually pretty cool!
Okaay.
Alright, so there's something wrong with all the TV's in the house.
Is that what I'm supposed to be gathering here?
Somewhere up here maybe?
Like this TV antenna?
Okay, slap that shit into shape and off we go!
Alright. TV's seem to be all in a 100% working order.
Talking head, flapping his gums in the distance, that's great.
Okay, Rocky.
C'mon.
*Mark cringes at the odd noise*
Stranger waves?
Ohhhh. Are we making the Stranger Things reference?
I do love Stranger Things.
Oh hi, Rocky.
Oh, okay.
Are you going to follow m- oh, there we go.
Okay, Rocky, there's no ghosts here, c'mon little boy!
C'mon... we got it.
*car starts up*
That was fun.
Ohh. Overcursed Inc., I'm at your home.
Oh, thank God! Here is the charlatan!
I beg your pardon?
Oh, please, I don't believe in your tall stories.
But my wife is verrryyy superstitious.
Install your stupid detectors and go away.
Click.
Okay, paranormal detection. Plug the detectors to the wall outlets.
Ohhkkayyyy.
I think- oh.
Sorry, don't mind if I throw all of my shit on your floor,
ya doubting doubter.
Okay.
Hello?
Hi-yah.
Okay.
Ohhhh.
Hah!
Oh- *confused Mark*
Okay! Well, that's doing its thing.
Grreaaattt?
I think?
Okay. Hello.
Hi.
Oh.
It's loOoOcked?!?
Why is it locked?
Okay. Heh!
Plug. Outlet. *poof* Whaaattt the heck happened there?!
Okay.
Well, I got some paranormal powers of my own.
Key.
Nothing else here.
ALRIGHTY THEN, JUST GONNA BARGE FURTHER INTO YOUR HOME!
Yeah, feel free not to thro- show me around!
Don't throw me around either, but, you know...
I'm not picky.
Okay, Rocky, you stay there!
It's a dangerous place around here!
Haaa!
Plug. Outlet?!
*nervous Mark cringes*
Ohhhkkaayyy! *dat cringe face tho*
Ohhkkayy!
Alrighty, then.
Turn the electricity back.
Is it back here?
Hello!
Okay.
And everything's perfectly normal again!
Well, that was easier than I thought it was.
Okay, don't mind my dopey walk,
as I go back. C'mon Rocky!
Don't go running off again!
C'mon!
*car starts up again* C'mon boi!
Aww, that's so cute.
Overcursed Inc., what can I do for you?
A... a BEAST lives in my house.
Please kill this awful thing,
and find a way to remove the bad smells.
Consider it DONE.
Ohhkay. Aww, come along Rocky! *OML THE DOGGO*
Aw, you're so cute!
Deodorant. Ooh. You ON to something? *machine wooshes*
Woah, alright then.
That was easier than I thought it was.
Don't mind me as I dope my way up the stairs.
Woah, find another one?
*more machine wooshing* Shhhhhh.
Alrrrighty then.
There's a pantry there.
Okay, goodbye.
*Mark cringes* Hellooo.
Was that the beast?
*woof* Was that the scurrying beast?
Ohhkay. *machine wooshes and Mark cringes*
Alrighty then.
Okkay!
Goodbye!
The fuck is going on here?
Why are there so many- why- if my job is to do paranormal investigation, why am I running around -
a house as a deodorizer?
That doesn't exactly make a lot of sense.
Okay, so there was something in the- *Dat face tho*
So there's something definitely in the pantry.
I got a bear trap with YOUR name on it!
Huh?!
Heaahhh!
K. I'ma see YOU.
I'll see you in- *crashing noise*
*more cringing*
Ohhhhhhh my GOD!
Dead rat?
Wait, it was just a rat?
That was the beast?
Man, I'm beginning to think this is all a sham!
I AM a charlatan!
I'm charlatan that's making some kind of money here. *r u sure?*
Overcursed Inc., what's your problem?
Dot, dot, dot.
Hellooo?
Mysterious scriptures, bedroom, CLEAN IT.
Ohkayyyyy?
I'm on my way!
Okie dokie, then.
Clean the marks on the wall in the bedroom.
Ohhh. This one's got a Castlevania style feel to it.
I don't think this is going to be a fun adventure.
I got my cleaning- where you going Rocky?
Where you going bud?
Huh?
Where you going boy?
Where you going?
There something over here?
Huh?
*growls* Oh, no. The backdoor is locked.
Well, that does not bode well for me.
I guess I'm just going to live with that.
Alright, Rocky. C'mon along.
Or stay there. Fine.
Okay.
Uhh.
Oh, yes, of course, the bedroom's all the way at the tipy-topy of the placey-wacey.
Alright.
Hello.
Ooh. Good boy.
No. *sprays blood-painted message* Go back to the car- you better not do nothing to my dog!
*sneakiplier*
Better not do nothing to my dog.
*creepy noises commence*
Hhhhiiiiii? Hello! Hi!
Oh, door's locked.
Oh, this is the game we're going to play here.
*sneakiplier back*
Uh huh.
Uh oh. Here we go.
Ohh. *BEWARE HEADPHONE USERS*
*loud noises* OHHHH Hi! *high-pitched screaming*
Okay, then!
Run away? But not without my cleaning spray!
I've got to finish the job!
Oh, jeez. That rocking chair sure is, uh, rockin'. *haha punny*
Wait.
Do I go- *pause* I can't go out- oh, no, I can't go out there. *slowly realizing he's dead*
Okay.
*crunching noise as the doggo is mutilated*
*cringing turns to pure shock and disgust*
(screaming) NOOOOOOOO!
*depressing music* (liek if u cri evrytim)
NOOOOOOOOO! *mark slowly dying inside* (me too fam)
*through the sad music* What?! *RIP doggo*
Fucking bullshit!
What the fuck?!
Oh, that's bullshit, my dog!
Why did you kill my dog?!
Oh, you as- oh. *confused* Ohhhhhkkkkaaayyyy?
Oh, you fuckers gonna get it now. *demolish the doggo killers*
FUCK YOU!
What are you even? What are you? Fuck you!
Oh, man, why'd you kill my dog?!
*raising pitch* Why did you kill my dog?!
Oh, my poor pup!
Oh, fuck you, fuck you, FUCK you.
Let's see, who else wants some?
Fuck you!
Alright.
How 'bout you?
Oh, oh, but, wait, wat, FUCK you.
Oh, wait ya, FUCK you double kill.
Anybody else in here? Huh? Good boy? FUCK OFF!
Killed my dog!
Okay, what else do I need to do?
Oh, no. I've got thirteen of fifteen.
(sadly) Ohhhhh.
Oh, NO! *OOOOOOOOHHHHNOOOOOO*
Go back to your car and enjoy your evening? I'm emotionally devastated!
Those goddamn ghosts!
The fucking ghosts!
*car starts nonchalantly*
Oh, and that's the end?!
Aww, man!
What the fuuuckkk?
You can't do that to me!
My poor pup! *RIP :'(*
Ohhhhhh.
Well, for a game that was made in TWO DAYS-
that was really good.
It had spooks, it had character, it had world-building.
It got me emotionally attached to a dog and then took the dog away from ME?
(sadly) You can't do that, I got to go hug Chica. *I NEEED CHICA TOO, THE PUPPER IS DED :'(*
But either way, that was Overcursed. That was pretty good for what they did in two days.
That's actually not bad at all.
Like, they could do a lot of stuff with this!
They might be able to expand this. I don't know where and I don't know how-
but that was pretty good.
So, I also wanted to mention before I go: the noon video today which is supposed to be the Monday vlog-
is going to be late, but for a good reason.
Today, and this is a big surprise, it's been very hard to contain this until today, but today-
we are going to be picking up Bob and Wade-
from the airport for a week full of making awesome videos for you guys.
And I'm just crazy excited to be able to see my friends again and it's been very hard to not tell-
you guys about it beforehand, but what I'm going to do is I'm going to be vlogging all-day long,
and then hopefully I'll have another vlog available later today, hopefully not too much later afternoon.
You guys will see it soon, it's just going to be a little late and I wanted to let you guys know about that-
so you weren't shocked, and appalled when the video was not there.
But either way, thank you guys so much for watching! Let me know what you thought of Overcursed and you can play it for yourself down through the link in the-
description below, and as always, I will see you in the next video. Buh-bye!
*outro* ((GOODBYE FRENS))